[Applause]
and finally new rule let's take a break
from bashing millennials for their safe
spaces
man buns and avocado toast and give them
credit for doing something right having
less sex than
other generations and so less babies
which is good for the planet
every week it seems there is a new study
about how little sex millennials are
having
researchers at the nunya business
institute
have found that people between the ages
of 18 and 30 just don't [ __ ] like they
used to
due to financial constraints career
aspirations and mostly an unwillingness
to put down the phone
also more young adults of course are
living at home and it's just
awkward to say dad can i borrow the bed
tonight
but instead of asking why america's
young people are having less sex
let's just be glad they are earth day is
coming up and i can't think of a better
gift to our planet
than pumping out fewer humans to destroy
it
people talk
people talk a lot about bringing a cloth
bag to the market and driving electric
but
the great under discuss factor in the
climate crisis is there are just too
many of us
and we use too much [ __ ] climate deniers
like to say there's no population
problem just like out the window of an
airplane
something but empty space down there but
it's not about space
it's about resources humans are already
using 1.7
times the resources the planet can
support
the world's population is increasing by
a million people every four and a half
days
and that's just on the 405.
we don't need smaller carbon footprints
we need less feet
i mean some days a simple trip to the
grocery store takes hours between the
traffic and
finding parking the lines i tell you i
don't know how my assistant does it
so it's no wonder millennials are
freaking out about having kids
they in generation z are waking up and
masked to the idea that way too early in
their lifetimes
the planet is going to be a [ __ ] show
alexandria ocasio-cortez recently did a
live q a on instagram where she said it
outright she said young people are
asking
is it okay to still have children now of
course the republicans had to respond
because they're obsessed with aoc
it's ironic she's against fossil fuel
yet she gives fossils fuel
utah's republican senator mike lee went
so far as to rebut
aoc's threat to stop breeding by saying
climate change is an engineering problem
and problems of human imagination are
not solved by more laws
but by more humans which is easy for
mike lee to say
he's a mormon when he dies he gets his
own planet
the solution to so many of our problems
at all times
and in all places is to fall in love
get married and have some kids
sounds like something colin firth says
at the end of a rom-com
but again remember mike lee belongs to a
cult
that believes all sorts of fantastical
nonsense
it's called the republican party
but
and i got to tell you liberals are also
at fault
on this issue i've never heard a liberal
say that
falling birth rates are a good thing
which they
are everyone talks about falling birth
rate like it means there's some
something desperately wrong with the
country they're depressed
they're not [ __ ] enough you know what
whatever problems are caused by falling
birth rates
aren't nearly as dire as the ones
brought on by overpopulation
in 1900 there were less than two billion
people on earth
now it's approaching eight we can't just
keep going on like this
the world is just too crowded when was
the last time you sat comfortably on an
airplane
wouldn't it
wouldn't it be nicer to just have fewer
people around
you know it's no secret that there are a
lot of jewish people in show business
so on on days here in hollywood when
it's a jewish holiday
the traffic delightful
delightful
that's what we should be shooting for to
make every day look like a jewish
holiday in los angeles
so please
masturbate don't procreate
yank it until trump is throwing paper
towels at you
and remember the best thing you can do
for earth is not have kids
die and stay dead have a great weekend
everybody
you